now if a tree falls
in a forest and no one's around to hear
it
does it make a sound well that's the
age-old philosophical thought experiment
about perception
and observation but after this weekend
we can modify it this way
if a trump march draws tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of peaceful
patriotic people to washington and no
one's around to report it
did it really occur well it was billed
as the million maga march that's more
than tens of thousands
uh and you look at it by the overhead
shots it could be one of the biggest
grassroots protests
the capital has ever seen attendees were
families
young old black white hispanic they came
from near
and far all to support the america first
agenda and to stand with the man who has
endured so much
in order to lead the movement
[Music]
for the very first time
one thing after another you know and uh
the american people know it
you know and you can see by the support
you gotta make sure our president get
back in that office
[Music]
now it's a fair guess that most in that
gigantic crowd are convinced that trump
won the election
and it's likewise reasonable for them to
conclude that
they don't have much trust in the u.s
media
now pockets by the way were even
chanting against this news channel for
what they perceive
as election night bias against the
president others
were rightfully outraged that few
networks were even carrying the rally at
all
and the ones who did were only
interested in insulting the attendees
the president's supporters they poured
into the streets of washington this
weekend
to try to give life to these unfounded
and baseless claims of a rigged election
how did this become normal i think with
some of these demonstrators
good luck getting a clear or fact-based
logical answer to some of the questions
you're opposing these people are
fundamentally a joke
these aren't serious people these are
members of a cult hope they get
frostbite
i hope they get frostbite is what he
said now remember
these talking heads are some of the kind
tolerant
unifying and loving people that biden in
harris claim make up their movement
well 73 million people voted for
president trump and
it's it's not too much for them to
expect is it
that the media treat them fairly and
respectfully
likewise it's not too much for them to
expect that only legal votes will be
counted
and that their votes must not be
nullified due to fraud
now for years now i've been speaking
about this type of honest hard-working
americans who came to washington over
the weekend
and throughout this time the so-called
elites in our nation's capital
have responded to the legitimate
concerns of american citizens with
mockery
and contempt it's dumbfounding to me
that the media and democrats still don't
understand what a
stupid strategy strategy it is to
alienate
and dismiss all of these americans
i think they're they're making the same
mistake they made back in 2009 and 2010
when the much smaller tea party movement
started
did you see the tea party movement as a
real political force this year
look i it
seems to be a very successful private
enterprise
nobody actually knows what they're for
we just know what they are against it's
not about
taxes this is about hating a black man
in the white house we call it astro turf
it's not really a grassroots movement
those of you who are watching certain
news channels that
in which i'm not very popular
and you see folks waving tea bags around
they thought that all that condescension
would make the movement go away
but it only made the tea party stronger
less than two years after those insults
republicans took control
of the house in 2010. now some of the
tea party candidates included those
little known people
christy gnome marco rubio ted cruz
rand paul tim scott and mike lee
and four years later the gop took
control of the senate
two years after that donald trump was
elected president
now the difference between the tea party
then and president trump's movement now
is that this movement now has a lot more
clarity about what it wants
the same trump economic and foreign
policy agenda that led to higher wages
fewer wars and whatever the final
electoral college tally is in this
election
this movement has a proven track record
of success on everything from achieving
our energy independence
to challenging china to fast-tracking a
covid vaccine to raising family incomes
the results were so impressive that not
only did president trump broaden his
coalition among working-class americans
but he helped grow the party's numbers
in the house
when all those wanted media experts with
all their credentials
were predicting the opposite they
claimed trump was going to shrink the
party remember that
especially among minorities wrong again
blacks and latinos are doing much better
on the trump
versus obama yeah absolutely opportunity
zone
which is
[Music]
black people on homes why couldn't the
networks find these people to interview
they were there
we found them in a biden administration
that that you just saw all those gains
gonna be flushed down the toilet his
handlers who are basically all the old
obama staffers believe in something
called the great reset
of capitalism i told you about this last
week it's a plan
to force a more equitable distribution
of global resources
translation most americans will have
less freedom
and less money except for the same
elites who always find a way around the
rules
like during the lockdowns when the
families of these mini tyrants
skirted the restrictions just like last
week
california governor gavin newsom was
dining with a prohibited number
of pals at that exclusive restaurant the
french laundry chicago mayor lori
lightfoot was caught partying maskless
in a massive crowd celebrating biden's
unofficial election win
no problem at all and pelosi well she
was going to have a big congressional
soiree until she was shamed into
canceling it
the american people are on to these
frauds the magamarcher certainly
couldn't have been clearer about
what love coveted lockdowns and
restrictions have done to america
it's like you know what trump said it
again the cure can't be worse than the
disease itself people we still need to
go on
trying to finish off any business that
was able to hang on by the skin of their
teeth and the last
closures they'll finish them off people
are hurting you know
nancy pelosi joe biden they don't talk
about caring about the american people
but you shut this country down for four
to six weeks
and you're going to absolutely it'll be
the final nail in the coffee for a lot
of small businesses
100 true but so far joe biden and his
handlers aren't listening
biden loves to talk about dignity and
unity and respect
but the time for talk is over and the
time for action is here
because if biden really wanted to unite
the country he wouldn't even be
entertaining the idea of destroying our
current economic recovery
with another devastating lockdown or
series of lockdowns
if biden really wanted to unite the
country he would not dismiss the
concerns of tens of millions of
americans about mail-in voting
instead he'd do something like i don't
know appoint a bipartisan commission to
answer
every question about how this election
was conducted
and to make certain that we will never
have to wait so long for an accurate
count
and if joe biden really wanted to unite
the country he would have
personally and on camera condemn the blm
and antifa thugs who beat kicked
and harassed trump supporters on
saturday
he has done none of these things he
still hopes this movement's just going
to go away
but that's not going to happen here are
a few hard truths for joe biden
his handlers and his enablers in the
press corps you know who you are
the pro-trump throngs didn't show up in
dc on saturday because of conservative
media
because we told them to they showed up
knowing they could be physically
attacked for doing so
because they love america
and lying about them insulting them
ignoring them
will only incite more violence and more
resentment
and opposition all americans deserve to
be heard
to be seen and to be safe it's the least
a government can do for its citizens
and that's the angle